صحيفه واشنطن بوست نقلا عن تقارير لمنظمه
سيتيزن لاب وشركه مايكروسوفت انا تطبيقا
اسرائيليا يعرف باسم كوادريم تم بيعه لعشر
دول واستخدم ضد صحفيين وسياسيين معارضين
وعاملين في منظمه غير حكوميه
واضافت صحيفه شركه مايكروسوفت اكتشفت اثار
برنامج التجسس في الاصدارات القديمه من
نظام التشغيل
التابع لشركه ابل بينما تتبعت شركه
البيانات لتعقب الضحايا بحسب الصحيفه فقد
ظهرت في البدايه معلومات كوادريم في كتيب
تسويقي واشارت الى ان بعض الدول لديها
قضايا تتعلق بحقوق الانسان وسوابق في
استخدام برنامج برامج التجسس على المعارضه
المحليه السلميه تاسست شركه كوادريم عام
2016 من قبل موظفين سابقين في شركه ان اس
او الاسرائيليه وفي عام
2021 اتهمت كوادريم وانا اسوا باستغلال
عيوب هواتف الايفون لتثبيت برامج تجسس
وتنضم الان الينا من واشنطن جودي واسبي
مديره شركه المخاطر الدوليه للانترنت
والامن السيبراني اهلا وسهلا بك في
التاسعه اذا بعد كل الضجه التي ثارت بسبب
تطبيق الان نحن بسبب تطبيق جديد
وكل العقوبات التي فرضت على يبدو انها لم
تثني اسرائيل او شركات اسرائيليه عن
برنامج جديد مع حجم خطر هذا البرنامج
برايك وكيف يختلف عن تجسس
للغايه
ونتحدث عن
موظفينا سابقين كانوا منخرطين في عمليه
استحداثه
نحن نتحدث عن برنامجا ليس بالضروره ان
نضغط على اي زر او على اي رابط يمكن هذا
البرنامج ان يسحب المعلومات من الهواتف من
الميكروفونات من الكاميرات يمكنها ان يسجل
الاتصالات نتحدث عن اداه استخباريه خطره
والان نحن في القرن الحادي والعشرين وهذه
الادوات لجمع المعلومات الاستخباريه يبدو
انها تظهر في كل مكان
يعني لماذا تلجا اسرائيل
وشركات اسرائيليه لمثل هذا التطبيق وهل
فعلا يمكن ان تكون هناك عقوبات اكثر صرامه
هذه الشركات انتاج تطبيق وراء اخر ثم تحدث
الاستفاده منه من جانب بعض الدول وبعد ذلك
يتم الاعتذار
للاسف يبدو الترجمه لا تصل ساعيد اتمنى ان
يتم الان
التعامل او اصلاح المشكله لا مشكله ساعيد
السؤال اذا
في السابق كان هناك عقوبات على ولكن واضح
ان الشركات الاسرائيليه لم يثنيها الامر
استمرت وها هي والدليل هذا البرنامج او
التطبيق الجديد
هل سنتوقع
تعامل اكثر صرامه الان ام سيكون هناك
تطبيق وراء تطبيق ويستفيد منه تستفيد منه
بعض الدول وثم ينتهي الامر
لا ادري يبدو ان هناك مشكله في الصوت وصول
الترجمه
اعتذر رغم ان هذا الملف ربما يعني في
اسئله كثيره وكنا نتمنى ان نواصل مع
ضيفتنا شكرا جزيلا لك اذا وجودي